alors constate dernière édition patrick
j'ai demandé à quelqu'un qui a été une
des révélations de la saison nous avons
su des centaines de la tg deux fois mais
vous ne vous lassez pas il était
vraiment la révélation de cette saison
de champigny s'achève ce soir j'en suis
très content d'attaquer
oui j'ai pensé que pour cette dernière
profitant de votre passage
votre votre don mais vous êtes également
appelé d'ailleurs oublié peut-être
apprendre limitation à not my hand a oui
je veux bien prendre la lutte à tailler
dit bonjour avocat donc les marges donc
les bars va bien tout va bien alors dit
moi je viens d'apprendre que tu sais
faire des imitant m'a dit vous savez sur
les imitant limitations sur tous les
billets de 100 francs à levier de cent
ponts avec lui dans la cave 1
c'est lui qui aurait dit moi mais des
imitations apprendre parler des
mutations de john sérieux la zone des
imitations politique je pourrais en
apprendre quelques-unes va par exemple
gaston defferre tu connais le vieux port
de marseille
bon alors pour être offerts faut être
réveillé mais on veut de la hat au coeur
que marseille
je vais me faire mise au point avant que
les gens qui prétendent qu à marseille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à boire à marseille on a fait voter les
morts c'est absolument folle et man ont
voté leur plein gré à ces jeux c'est peu
et mettez ça oui chez toi à la limite de
gaston defferre simon à ces
rassemblements
non mais non c'est pas vrai parce que le
garçon d'affaires et gaston defferre ne
boit pas et c'est ça était grave alors
dit moi il faut arrêter les zones
british crois qu'il faut essayer de
faire des artistes des musiciens 1,6 car
par exemple
giscard tu peux m'aider à cergy ce cas
on y va c'est qu'ils jouent de
l'accordéon alors allons-y verschueren
de la politique un mouchoir bagdad
beauchamp de l'eau gèle bonsoir but est
bien en temps quand je suis un président
de la république
je suis particulièrement courtes ont le
choix de passer ces témoins
voilà y aller il ya les planteurs le
chanteur les chante
le napoléon de la chanson georges lama
qui s'essuie cas les cheveux comme ça
ces cas les cheveux comme ça fait un peu
pour voir si mal et tu sais ce qu'ils
foutent pas mal ccc se pencher comme ça
tu vas mettre tes mains tu sais quand il
rit ça fait ça fait tout éclater tu vois
un bon savon fait moi le riz on peut
pourvoir fait c'est bien ça ressemble à
rien merci merci mon cher cher jamin et
paie ici
des particules avant caen ce soir dans
son émission 47 de plus à un jeu les ir
qu'elle vous fait de recevoir enfin
depuis si longtemps
ce talent il a sur son plateau de java
chez toi c'est moi dalida tiens j'ai
quelque chose pour toi tu as ta imite
d'ali daei mais j'aimerais c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal
alors s'il ya quelques mois à temps puis
lâchez pas si tu le connais ça c'est
celui-là il y défend dalida dans ma main
ça monsieur qui fume beaucoup tu vois
j'ai très très bien mais parce que je
suis bien content la veille un être à
l'émission dirigeants des chambres
dalida que je défends est enfin bien
gaddour ilyasova perles attend un peu
bien je trouve pas le temps pour
deux cas d'ingestion lorthiois n'ont
jamais plus j'en ai plus mais je veux
faire autre chose les limitations que tu
connais pas regarde bien regarde moi
bien ça dit quelque chose ça marche mais
par ailleurs mieux rien
tu reconnais ordinaire
voilà ça y est
ça y est et c'est pas facile hein et
émulateurs
si je me tais toi non ménard agissait
dans lac
j'imite voilà il causait il faut des
gants de boxe attend attend bon alors
alors alors alors oui on imagine
d'offres est reconnue alors sonné on
imagine un choc entre entre coluche et à
taez alors à droit de réponse on t'avait
pas prévenu
ouais
et oui d'accord merkel voilà pourquoi à
moi de répondre réponse oui oui et basse
le thème de l'émission va plus va-t-on
supporter encore longtemps ta taille et
est connue et je ne s'est pas posé la
question s'il vous plaît le fait de
cocher
on est au pied du mur de huy a toujours
un or jamais alors toujours pourquoi
c'est très clair
comme d'habitude je dire que c'est pas
une raison plasticien je leur ai fait
parler et parler jamais dit
m
mais c'est très bien que tu m'intéresses